hey reject nation how y'all doing it's
Greg Alva here John is me we're gonna
watch the trailer from Marvel
cloak-and-dagger that says a reficul
trailer number one before we do that I
wanted to say thank you to everyone
who's been following us over at patreon
wanted to mention on this video because
this is a TV show and over at page from
we've been doing a lot of TV show
reactions over there I myself cover
attack on Titan episodes of the flash
catching up this week John covers
Riverdale he's also been covering
Marvel's runaways together we cover
Jessica Jones and we cover my hero
academia looking for maybe another show
to add on to the list and occasionally
we'll cover a movie we also do weekly
Q&A is over there so thank you to
everyone who's been following us over at
patreon love to have you we've tried
doing the you know cutting down the
reactions into ten minutes putting them
on YouTube like how other channels have
done I don't know why YouTube
specifically goes after our Channel but
it's like every single one of our TV
show reactions has gotten blocked even
the 10-minute cuts and we followed all
the format's that we've seen other
people do we've experimented but they
always get blocked they're all on
patreon now first
[Music]
New Orleans is a rollercoaster of
destruction and rebirth
Walden's fire disease war oh you know it
came down to two people the divine
the cloak-and-dagger
I feel like have to be perfect
I'd have to do it everything right
[Music]
there's something about fear that pushes
me past my whole life
I think we need to talk
[Music]
we touch sexy assess our limits
[Music]
it's the same as it was for all the
others most keeps was used together
Universal is now the universe is gonna
put you guys together until the show
needs to end and then they'll finally
kill one of you hopefully you know I've
seen most of the Marvel shows that have
come out only a couple I haven't seen
I've seen a good amount of this DC TV
shows this definitely looks more like
one of those CW shows actually I got
more of like a Black Lightning vibe but
more like the teen angst version of The
Black Lightning ships it's just black
lightning into the runaways or something
yeah Runaways has that melancholy
quality manatee melancholy vibe may
never make sense based on cloak and
dagger these dudes are high school right
here which I can get on board with I
didn't think I get on board for that for
Runaways but I enjoyed the hell out of
Runaways seeing it here it looks
interesting
I feel like fans at the comic books of
cloak and dagger are really excited for
this because they're fans of cloak and
dagger the comic books for someone like
myself who's not that familiar of a
cloak and dagger I'm at this point where
I'm thinking this looks good I'm not
like I have to go check this out though
there's not something in me where I'm
super gravitated towards what they're
presenting I usually feel that way about
a good amount of the Marvel show
trailers I'm I'm usually like this looks
cool I don't really know about it this
seems like this will have some real grit
to it though you know as despite its
like aesthetic reminding me more of a CW
show I feel like it'll have a little
more of that gritty side the Marvel
shows like Runaways will have or
borderline Netflix territory will have
the two main actors but I really like
about these performances here is that it
seemed like very subtle performances
especially the dude like the dude seems
like he's giving a really subtle
performance yeah that was probably what
pulled me into this trailer the most was
just the two of them and the idea that
you know now we have a pairing because
you know there are only so many ways to
remix what a superhero series is gonna
be
you know one of those ways to me anyway
you know we have like ensemble pieces we
have ones that center around like one
person or a specific group of people
teaming up you know for something
special and this is like two people who
are connected by something and I do like
you know the imagery and the
juxtapositions of the light and the dark
on them both and all that there's some
cool like visual symbolism there hinting
at and piggybacking off that scene that
they released before that like
pickpocket scene you know III further
you know kind of grab their chemistry
off this and like you said you know the
kind of subtlety of their performances
and you know that the white girls the
thief and not the black guy I know we
were remix it we're changing it up
defying defying students I mean all
these Marvel shows are connected they're
all part of the MCU the bigger world
anyhow the event Runaways being a Hulu
and they said that this will be
streaming on Hulu as well part of me is
kind of hoping that they can cross this
over would Runaways in some capacity oh
this is New Orleans and The Runaways are
in LA that would be cool though for them
to all kind of crossover together and
use all their powers well on everything
shot in Louisiana now so yeah hopefully
that'll make it easier it should be The
Runaways and cloak-and-dagger that take
on Thanos in part two yeah after Thanos
kills all the Avengers kills all the
movie characters and then part two all
the TV heroes have to step up early all
the properties crossing they've been
working on this show for a while because
they had like trailers coming out for
like a year now or something like that
these shows have been dropping for a
while and it's finally coming out in
June I'm wondering how much reshoots
they've done or how much reworking
they've been doing on this series
because it's been a while it's been like
being filmed it looks like the work will
pay off who knows who knows people will
tell me if they like it or not they
always do yeah I mean other than like
the cast looking good and the appeal of
some type of grid and like you said a
duo the first like duo show to exist
honestly it kind of looks like a basic
teen drama I'm kind of mixed on the
effects the effects look good but they
don't look inspired for a show like this
especially I maybe it's just what I've
learn to expect is like I know y'all
don't have like a mega CG budget
especially if you're doing this on
freeform or something like that or even
Hulu I don't really go in kind of hoping
that there will be some crazy CGI I
thought what they have here is is
appropriate but you know it'll it'll
take seeing the rest of the show to well
know a Marvel TV shows the episodes will
take a long time to build up and it
won't be heavy reliant on all the action
sequences I'm sure when it comes down to
the context of it the effects will be
just fine alright guys well are you
gonna take the time in your schedule of
all the TV shows in the world to watch
Marvel's cloak and dagger are you gonna
stop watching all other TV shows just so
you can keep up with all the Marvel's
yeah basically what your life will gonna
soon make that you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
really get notified every time one of
our vids is up and you can check us out
on patreon people see you later